- Well hey, let's bring
in the other judges--
- No, let's just keep
it you and I, I'm happy.
- We have to bring them
in, they've been waiting.
- I'm not ready!
(laughs)
- Oh my gosh!
- Honey, the blue shirt.
- [Terry] I didn't wanna see that.
- [Sofia] What's going on?
- (mumbles) a horror movie.
- I love you so much right now, oh my God.
- What are you doing?
- You wanna know honestly
what I'm doing, Simon?
- I have a feeling and
I don't wanna see it.
- You inspired me, Simon,
that you were able to
(microphone cuts out).
Well, here's what it is.
Terry Crews is the consummate host,
good friend and everything.
What is he known for
besides hosting our show?
- Having huge pecs.
- And able to control them, right?
(laughs)
And you can do it now, too, right?
- I can do it now, as well, yep.
- [Howie] Let's see.
- Um, hang on, I don't know if they show.
Okay, hang on one second.
- There it is, yes, yes.
- I mean it's not as good as you, Terry,
but I'm getting there.
- No, it's--
- Hey, guys, I've been practicing at home.
I'm not there yet, but--
- Oh my God!
- Look.
(laughs)
Edit the show you can edit
out the strings and everything
so I look more talented, no?
- You know what, Howie, you
know what you look like?
You know when you get one of
these really bad auditions
on the show and all you're
thinking is how quickly
can I get you off the stage?
We're in that kind of place right now.
- Are you giving me a red buzzer?
- Yes, millions of them.
- Hey Sofia, how you doin'?
- How are you, Kelly?
Hi everybody!
- (mumbles) Sofia!
- Heidi, gosh that eye
makeup I'm in love with,
that is amazing.
- Amazing!
- Hi!
- [Simon] Where is Heidi?
- [Kelly] She's on the other,
I had to flip the screen,
yeah, there's a lot of us.
It's a large Zoom call.
- Oh okay.
Hi Heidi!
- Hi!
- Everybody out there
please welcome Howie Mandel,
Heidi Klum, Sofia Vergara, and
the host of AGT, Terry Crews.
- Hey, hey.
- All right, y'all, so I'm
gonna start with Howie,
naked boy number one.
Have the rest of these guys apologized
for not taking your concern
about germs seriously?
(laughs)
- Oh, my gosh.
No, no.
Some people call it a
pandemic, I call it told ya.
(laughs)
No, they haven't apologized.
I don't want an apology.
I mean all kidding aside,
this is the nightmare
I've lived in my own mind for
the last 64 years of my life
and now it was nice to
wake up and find out
it was only a nightmare.
Now every day I'm waking
up and finding out
you're all in the nightmare with me.
- We're all in it with you, Howie.
- [Kelly] Definitely scary.
- There you are.
Hi, Heidi!
- Hi!
- You look great!
- I know I love her eye
makeup and her hair.
I'm just like what, okay.
So Heidi, actually that's
kind of a good segue
because you had your
own COVID scare, right?
You're doing well now, right?
- I'm fine, I never had it
but you know at the time
when it just kind of hit America
and when it hit Los Angeles,
I all of the sudden got sick.
I came to set and I had
a fever, I had a cough,
I wasn't feeling good, you know
when you have your body ache
everywhere and I got there and
I told someone immediately.
I was like I'm not
feeling good and you know
there's this corona thing going around
and immediately they had the
medic there coming to see
how high my fever was and
they dismissed me immediately
and send me home.
and thankfully I never had it and yeah,
I guess everyone did the right
thing for sending me home,
but that's why you know
Terry got to come and sit in
my seat which was, I'm sure,
so much fun for all you guys.
- By the way, Sofia was thrilled.
(laughs)
- No, Heidi, I need you.
- I miss you guys so much though.
It was very strange to leave
because I'm very German.
I'm always very on time, I do as I'm told
and I've never really been
sick and been sent home,
so I felt so bizarre.
But it was such a--
- You know honestly,
I never told you this,
Sofia said look, I think she should leave
for the whole season.
(laughs)
- No, I didn't!
- You can't take it back now.
- [Terry] Oh!
- [Kelly] But you still
found a socially distant way
to get your hair done?
And I just wanna say, what the hell?
This photo is so hot.
- I mean I have to tell
you know we have someone
in the family who has
(people talking over speaker)
immune disease, so
we've been super careful
from the very beginning
like not going out,
like washing everything
because when you have someone
around you with an auto-immune disease,
it's like extra on high alert.
So I never really, I
haven't really seen anybody,
gone anywhere, done anything,
but you know we were like,
okay we have to do this super
proper, with the umbrella.
We have all the masks on and everything,
just do the highlights.
I mean I did all the
washing and everything else,
but he just came by and
did a few highlights
because I'm not a real blonde.
You know what I'm saying?
So it was like.
- I hear you on the auto-immune thing,
that is why I was so scared.
I have an auto-immune
disease, so I was like what?
And I freaked out, so I feel you on that.
And I love the photo.
Forget the umbrella, no one's
looking at the damn umbrella.
(laughs)
- Exactly.
- Well, I didn't wanna get
my outfit all messed up.
You know how that is when
you get a little bleach.
- Girl, if I was rockin'
what you and Sofia had,
I'd be walkin' around naked
in the frozen food section.
(laughs)
I was like I mean it's a beautiful thing,
God had great (mumbles) when He made--
- That is funny, that is funny.
- I was just like, wow.
Wait, Sofia, so is it true your husband,
this is one of my favorite things.
Your husband, Joe, holds a
Dungeons and Dragons club
in your house?
I mean these photos and
once I heard about this,
I actually--
- Do you play?
Do you play this?
- I want to.
I'm such a nerd alert.
I literally went down a little
rabbit hole of watching it
on YouTube of him talking
about who's come in and out
of the game and it's the
most random group of people.
So this is all true?
- It's super weird, they're really weird.
(laughs)
But (laughter over speaker)
that he comes and do it here
in the house, I mean now
that they are in quarantine,
they're doing it on Zoom.
So they have still been playing.
It's crazy 'cause they
can do something this game
for like six, seven hours
and they sing, they clap,
I don't know what
they're doing down there.
It's like something really
weird that I can't understand,
but it sounds fun.
- You know most people who
play Dungeons and Dragons
don't even meet pretty
girls, to marry one.
(laughs)
- I was like I love that
you ended up with a guy
that plays Dungeons and Dragons.
- Joe is a complete
nerd, I always tell him
that he's trapped in the wrong body.
It's like they put a nerd in this body
and it doesn't make any sense to me.
- My man, he's like me,
he's right there with me.
(laughs)
I'm gonna play with him, I'm telling you,
we're gonna do Dungeons
and Dragons together.
I love it.
- Oh you have to.
Kelly and you can come, too.
- Oh, it looks like a man's club,
it looks like Little Rascals,
like women aren't invited, but--
(laughs)
- No, no, sometimes there's been,
no, there have been girls
playing here many times.
I mean it's a small percentage,
but yes, they do come and play here.
- I (mumbles) like in the lou.
- Okay, so wait, Howie.
You just actually celebrated
your 40th wedding anniversary
in lockdown, did y'all
do anything special?
'Cause I remember your birthday
you brought an elephant in
for her, so, or for her birthday.
- Um, did I do anything special?
Yes, I took her to the
guest room. (laughs)
- That's exciting.
- And what happened there?
- What happened?
- Yeah I know, were you
christening the house
or what's happening?
(laughs)
- We've christened it,
we've been here for years
and decades and decades.
You know in quarantine,
there were no surprises.
It's just we said we wanna
redo our vows and she came up
with one vow and then her
vow was enough already.
(laughs)
- Oh, she doesn't mean that.
- Oh my gosh.
Wait, so okay, Sofia,
you're the newest judge,
so what kind of acts are you liking?
What are you digging about the show?
- You know what, I was
having such a great time.
We had to stop because of
all the virus situation,
but I was having such a great time.
I mean it was better than
I thought it was gonna be.
I loved everybody, I think
we all have gotten along
from the beginning.
The being there in the stage,
the contestants, everything.
I mean I am very lucky to
be part of this group now.
- Oh, that's cool.
I know that's what I love about
being part of "The Voice."
I love when I love going to work.
You know you love when
you love going to work
and showing up and everybody's cool and--
- Kelly, you can't talk about
the opposition, darling.
- Oh, what?
Opposition?
- The opposition, you know you're like
our opposition, "The Voice."
- Oh, wait, but we're not
even on at the same time.
- It doesn't matter, it's
still kind of competition, so--
- Being very competitive,
Mr. Simon Cowell.
(laughs)
- [Simon] Let me just
say bad things about it.
- Wait, we're not even
on at the same time.
(laughs)
- It doesn't matter, you
exist, it happens there.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay,
good answer, good answer.
♪ And the mother really shows herself ♪
♪ Everything will be all right ♪
♪ As she steps in rhythm ♪
♪ To the sounds of the sidewalk ♪
♪ As she steps in ♪
(cheering)
- What they did today has moved
me to this point right now.
(cheering)
- Hey y'all, I'm back with the team
of "America's Got Talent,"
Simon Cowell, Howie Mandel,
Heidi Klum, Sofia
Vergara, and Terry Crews.
All right, so Terry, you
used your golden buzzer
for the Voices of Our City choir.
What did you love about them?
- Oh my God.
First of all, the fact that
here we had a homeless choir
who came up from San Diego.
They wrote their own music,
they did their own things,
it was absolutely, it just
moved me beyond belief.
I was in tears and I knew
as soon as I saw them
that I had to give it.
I just rushed the stage
because the opportunity
that each one of these men
and women took was a risk.
You know they've been cast
away, they've been marginalized
for so long and to get the
confidence to get up there
and try something like
this, I had to reward 'em
and let me tell you,
they were outstanding.
One of my best, best things
I've ever done in my life.
And it's like that for
all our golden buzzers.
- I love the golden buzzer.
Well, Heidi, who did you
pick for your golden buzzer?
- Mine was for Christina
Rae, she's a singer.
I fell in love with her immediately
and she also has the most
heart-wrenching story,
but I always go with my gut
instinct and I just loved her
and I loved her performance,
I loved her voice.
And I don't know, maybe it's
gonna be my golden buzzer
who's gonna win it all this time.
- Kelly, technically I think she might be
one of the best singers
we've ever had on the show.
- [Terry] Yes.
- Really?
- Yeah, honest to God.
Have you watched that movie,
"Twenty Feet from Stardom"?
- Yeah, with Darlene Love, yeah.
- Okay, she's like one
of those great singers
and she hasn't been given a
shot yet, but I mean her voice
is off the chart, this girl.
- Oh, that's exciting!
I love hearing, I love
people in their element
just really nailin' it in what they do,
that's so (microphone cuts out).
Well, Simon who did you
use your golden buzzer for?
- Well, I actually gave my
golden buzzer to some dancers
and look, I'm not a dance
expert, believe it or not.
(laughs) It'd be like me
giving a golden buzzer
to a fashion designer,
you know it's like not really my thing.
But and a bit like what Terry was saying,
you know their story often
has a lot to do with it
and there was something about these guys
and they were talking to
me and I could see how much
it meant to them and then I
was feeding off the audience.
And you don't think
about it in the moment,
it's just like you just wanna
give them that extra boost.
I've got a feeling that they
might be in the top three
at the end, these guys.
- Wow.
- One of those guys threw his shoe on.
How do you throw your shoe on?
Not off, on!
And that's how there was a
miracle, I was like (laughs).
- So wait, Howie, who did you
use your golden buzzer on?
- Okay, mine's the only
one that hasn't aired yet
and I gotta tell you something,
I've been on the show
and I keep mentioning this
ad nauseum for like 11 years,
this is the first time that
I've pressed the golden buzzer
for something that has never
graced the stages of AGT.
It's not a singer, it's not a
magician, it's not a dancer,
it's not music, it's something
you've never seen on AGT,
so (microphone cuts out).
- Howie, I've seen it in the cut.
This person is phenomenal and
actually it was good then,
it's even better now.
- Wow!
- I can't even wait to watch this now.
- I know, I'm like this is--
- You've set this up so well,
I can't wait to see this now.
- I know it's like the worst tease.
I'm like, okay, cool, I got to wait.
So wait, Sofia, this is
your first time to use
your golden buzzer.
Who was your choice?
- It was super exciting
because it was on my first day,
so I don't even know why I had the feeling
that I needed to do that.
It was for Roberta Battaglia,
she's a 10-year-old girl.
She was amazing and you know
what, after I've been watching
the show, I still really think
that it was the perfect
choice, right guys?
- This girl is super, super talented.
- Simon, I don't know if you know this,
'cause you spend a lot of time
in the UK, but Kelly Clarkson
is also a singer who
was discovered on a show
not like on our--
(laughs)
- We can't talk about other shows!
- All I can say is whoever
was judging that year
must have been amazing.
(laughs)
- He nailed it, they nailed it.
All right, well speaking of judges.
In the judges' cuts episodes,
you're together for the first
time, how great is that?
- Oh.
- You know what, we're going
into unknown territory here,
Kelly, so this is I swear when
I say we are makin' this up
day by day, we are making
this up day by day.
But I've gotta hand it to
everyone on the call here,
everyone's embraced it,
everyone's contributed ideas.
Number one priority, keep safe.
Second priority, get the
contestants to be amazing.
Third, have fun.